hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen die heute zum zweiten teil
wollen
bei movistar planet geht es darum dass
ich diese bescheuerte person da bin der
sie tatsächlich gar nicht mal so ähnlich
und bei dem spiel geht es einfach darum
dass wir in einer virtuellen stadt leben
wir können uns mit anderen leuten
unterhalten kontakte knüpfen wir zeit
rapid i also wir schauen mal direkt
reinere level 4 wähler ein geschenk
eines lecks wetter und eine cute hätte
also der danke dafür mégane ist vor
einer woche schon mal movistar denn auf
dem kanal gespielten das war ja mal
nicht so
ja das war schon witzig ich würde sagen
ich soll meinen typen hier erstmal ein
bisschen rum und zwar als erstes die ich
mir das fashion gott zuvor waren wir
immer nur am strand
ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
eventuell mal in das café und schauen
wer hier so alles am start ist bisher
nur ich ich würde sagen wir gehen
einfach mal zu ihr hier vorne hin
könnten die ja mal ein bisschen antanzen
da die auf unser tanzen wie ich reagiert
er begeht die weg ich schickte erst mal
eine freundschaftsanfrage ihr status ist
liebe liebe mein gott was ist eigentlich
mein status die stinken nach soja dass
mein status also die cheney hat meine
freundschaftsanfrage angenommen das
heißt ich fragte beste freude sein
wollen marc gini ob er dein bester
freund
ich dachte sie also mal schauen was die
cheney darauf antwortet er mich fügt
einfach noch mal ein paar andere leute
hier hinzu die sich gerade hier im café
befinden auch den bus 112 2 39 39 800
irgendeiner ausgeschlossen
keine ahnung was das ist level 0 spiele
mit einem h es gibt aus teterow story
ich bin der wertvollen diamanten sport
war cheney hat eingeschrieben kann nicht
gut tanzen kannst du haseloff
mit dir habe ich aber gar nicht geredet
wie ich finde es dumm
du bist ein frosch zum frosch ist das
luegallee das bin ich nicht aber da ja
gut ich würde sagen wir verlassen mal
das szene-café ich habe 29 1084
freundschaftsanfragen schauen wir
erstmal die nachrichten rein
hier haben mir ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
leute irgendwie wird geschrieben
das sind alles meine mädels hier also
keine ahnung was die mir alle mitteilen
wollen das kann ich auf jeden fall nicht
alles durchlesen nämlich habe 84
freundschaftsanfragen von erkennst du
nicht blumen 69 690 juliana account
schatten boss 14 oben steht da doch ich
habe vier aktivitäten
ich habe 2028 autogramme ich habe 389
läuft erhalten filme in denen ich habe
mit filme die mich mitspieler du kamel
shop.de ist das war's also dem die der
fünf sterne ich habe allerdings noch
immer keine freundin
dass ich eine freundin
vielleicht kennen lerne und die dann
dass man freunde nicht dafür gehe ich
einfach mal ganz normal an strand und
schaue ich mir hier so ein bisschen um
was hier so viele leute her laufen die
frage ich denn jetzt leute ob die mit
mir zusammen sein wollen hallo ich bin
ein einsames hässliches opfer und suche
jetzt einfach mal auf als freund
hinzufügen und danach können wir ja
zusammen
ein wahnsinnsspiel bis es scheißegal ich
gebe karg auf die card xoxo besser
freundinnen kann man eben skatepark
finden hallo ich bin single wie
einspringen und suche freundin for life
[Musik]
2009 als die schwarze rose willst du
meine freundin sein bitte diana 5 69 84
waren also viel zeit in ihrem namen der
gerade geschrieben einem das heißt da
willst du meine freundin sein okay sie
fragt warum das heißt ich muss jetzt
einen richtig guten gründen warum sie
meine freundin sein sollte ich habe
keine freundin
da willst du oder nicht anna also ich
habe der anna 5698 jetzt noch eine
chance gegeben
das bist du denn eine gegenfrage 740
dabei die fische meine allerletzte frage
ist anna willst du meine freunde seid ja
oder nein nicht wollen was wenn alle
antworten jetzt alleine beziehung kommen
viele fanden elefant ein ganzes leben
lang weiter im single sein
der vater ich bin ein baum des atlas
leid da wenn es euch gefallen hat
abonniert main kanal wenn nächste woche
neuer teil kommen sollen und schreibt
mir die kommentare was ihr von anna
halte ich bin einfach ein neuer verein
[Musik]